alors on est
vous emmène en 1981
3 au bord du rio tambo en amazonie
péruvienne c'est un bivouac
il fait nuit et là ernesto un musicien
ashaninkas qui est de la communauté
bethania va cueillir une feuille de deux
herbes et les assemble très simplement
et commence à jouer de cet instrument à
cordes dont la caisse de résonance et sa
bouche
là c'est surprise ses émerveillements
c'est un instrument éphémère qui est
immédiatement disponible et qu'on n'a
pas besoin de transporter donc j'étais à
côté de lui
c'est un moment qui est resté dans la
mémoire et c'est le début d'un
cheminement la deuxième étape du
cheminement c'est un constat très simple
c'est la terre a une dimension fini on
connaît bien qu'on peut pas modifier
donc on a des ressources qui sont
limitées et la population mondiale
continue d'augmenter
nous serons entre 11 et 12 milliards en
2100 et on voit bien tout esprit
cartésien voit bien que on risque
d'avoir un petit problème à résoudre
si on reprend ce constat on dit qu'il ya
des ressources disponibles constante
il ya aussi plus d'êtres humains mais on
a aussi une croissance industrielle qui
est limitée qui a de l'ordre de 1 2% par
an et il ya aussi un désir après
légitimes de chacun à avoir accès aux
biens légitimes si on mélange ses quatre
ingrédients dont on s'aperçoit bien
qu'il ya un gros point d'interrogation
qui se pose sur notre avenir
mais ce point d'interrogation c'est
aussi un moteur fantastique pour trouver
des solutions
j'ai relevé juste une phrase de gandhi
il en vivre simplement pour que les
autres puissent simplement vivre
je vais vous parler de trois rencontres
qui sont pour moi qui vont complètement
dans ce sens
la première rencontre elle a eu lieu à
bruxelles dans une conférence de
organisé par le groupe physique ce fort
développement de la société européenne
de physique
l'idée c'était de d'utiliser
l'expérience de physiciens européens
pour aider des pays émergents à trouver
des solutions technologiques qu'ils
soient qu'ils résolvent une
problématique de développement
le professeur rabbani qui travaille à
l'université de dacca nous a montré
comment avec de la paille avec un
plateau en bambou pas en noir c'est un
plateau qui est utilisé dans tous les
dance toutes les familles du bangladesh
avec trois ou quatre feuilles de
polypropylène transparente on pouvait
faire un four solaire qui permet de
détruire les bactéries dans les eaux de
ruissellement
donc c'est une solution très économique
très simple pour résoudre un problème de
santé publique
critique au bangladesh où les
inondations sont fréquentes
si on traverse l'atlantique on arrive au
pérou dans une école qui s'appelle
l'école andine de spectroscopie qui a
été imaginé par des collègues du cea de
saclay l'idée c'est de danser gay mais
aussi de monter des travaux pratiques
pour les étudiants en physique du pérou
et l'équateur leur désir d'apprendre
leur désir d'expérimenter et souvent
très limité par l'accès à
l'instrumentation et eduardo montoya qui
est un responsable scientifique de
l'institut péruvien d'énergie nucléaire
a développé des spectroscope des
spectromètres avec du matériel de
récupération
par exemple vous avez là un spectromètre
qui utilise un morceau de dvd comme
réseaux optiques en y additionnant un
appareil photo du commerce
on arrive à avoir un spectromètre qui
écoute aux environs de 40 fois moins que
le modèle commercial
bien entendu il n'a pas les mêmes
performances
mais ses performances sont suffisantes
pour donner l'envié d'expérimenter aux
étudiants et pour moi c'est aussi
l'exemple que
arrivé à créer et à développer les
laboratoires de recherche abordables
accessibles
c'est une façon aussi de d'aider à
trouver les solutions technologiques aux
problèmes et locales aux problèmes des
pays émergents mais c'est aussi deux
d'aider des étudiants à progresser dans
l'ordre dans leur domaine de façon de
local
troisième exemple troisième rencontre un
collectif espagnol qui s'appelle john
punk c'est un collectif féminin dont les
membres se définissent comme étant des
sorcières cyborg de la gynécologie
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
elles veulent donner accès au diagnostic
et au dépistage gynécologique à des
femmes en grande difficulté sociale ou à
des femmes qui sont dans des camps de
réfugiés ou à les travailleuses du sexe
qui n'ont pas accès au système médical
national
elles ont donc développé un kit gynéco
d'urgence composé d'une centrifugeuse
d'un incubateur et d'un microscope
tout ça s'est fait dans la ligne dans la
droite ligne du do it yourself
donc vous vous lavez la la centrifugeuse
donc on part d'un lecteur dvd récupéré
sur un un ordinateur voué à la casse on
rajoute quelques pièces fait en
imprimantes 3d de l'électronique en open
source et on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
aller sur le terrain et commencé à faire
du dépistage deal écologique
alors qu'y at il de commun entre l'arc
musical de la chaîne inka le collectif
espagnol jean ping le spectromètre
péruviens ou le four solaire bain du
bangladesh a d'abord une analyse très
précise de l'usagé du besoin
il ya aussi d'utilisation et la prise en
compte du de l'environnement économique
et des pièces disponibles immédiatement
disponibles et aussi la volonté
d'utiliser des ressources locales et
bien entendu autour de tout ça il ya
beaucoup d'ingéniosité et c'est tout
cela qui est l'innovation frugal alors
l'innovation frugal elle a été décrite
par navirad joue le livre que qui avait
été mentionné tout à l'heure et na vi m
résumé l'innovation fri gagnent en une
seule phrase qui est faire plus avec
moins
alors je vous engage à réfléchir et à
observer votre environnement au travers
de cette double notion de l'innovation
être égalité et je suis quasiment sûr
que vous trouverez des voies de solution
à notre problème du démarrage des
relations frugal c'est aussi un élément
essentiel d'une d'un nouvel écosystème
de développement économique ou de
créativité économique auquel participent
aussi des des process comme le design
thinking l'économie circulaire usage des
mook les hd open source ou l'économie
participative et cet ensemble est en
train de créer une nouvelle économie qui
est bien entendu de la création de
valeur mais qui est aussi facilite
l'accès aux biens essentiels à la
majorité de la population mais
l'innovation fri galles c'est aussi une
rupture c'est une rupture par rapport
aux pratiques qui sont issus de la
consommation reine que l'on peut
connaître mais elle est déjà là elle est
déjà là il suffit de regarder
il suffit de surfer sur le net il suffit
d'aller visiter par exemple bloc des
veilleurs de l'innovation frugal pour
s'apercevoir qu'elle est déjà très
présente mais pour la mettre en route
pour aller la chercher il va falloir
résoudre à et
forcer un certain challenge sociétal
être dans l'innovation frugal c'est une
nouvelle forme de société il faut qu'on
modifie notre comportement ce qui veut
dire qu'on n'est plus un spectateur du
monde mais on devient un acteur de notre
futur ça veut dire aussi qu'on va
peut-être privilégié l'usagé à la
propriété mais on le fait déjà sur les
v10 ou les autolib et tout ça va
demander pas mal d'efforts donc je
voulais vous voudrez vous montrer deux
exemples qui sont des réalisations qui
ont déjà quelques années mais qui
montrent à quel point les innovations
frugal peut apporter au niveau de la vie
quotidienne le premier exemple c'est le
tube rome
donc c'est afrique du sud c'est la
problématique c'est comment transporter
de l'eau quand on est à pied on est loin
du puits alors il ya la solution
traditionnelle qui est de prendre un pot
en terre se le mettre sur la tête et
marcher pendant 20 km ça limite le
volume d'eau transporter et puis ça pose
quelques problèmes de santé au niveau
des vertèbres
la solution c'est peut-être imaginer ce
container cylindrique que l'on fait
rouler en traînant avec une corde
c'est du plastique recyclé c'est une
corde de fabrication locale c'est de
l'innovation frugal l'autre exemple
plus étonnant c'est la cathédrale de
tricheurs en 2011
un tremblement de terre a détruit
partiellement la cathérale principal de
recherche et la communauté catholique a
souhaité avoir très vite un nouveau
centre de culte et de rencontres un
architecte japonais a imaginé et décider
une nouvelle cathédrale dont la
structure est entièrement en carton donc
du bataillon recyclable et recyclé et
recyclable est aussi une conception un
design qui fait que chaque partie est
transportable dans un container standard
donc une diminution des coûts énormes
donc imagination
résolution d'un problème économique est
ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
cette cathédrale a été payée entièrement
sur des dons privés puisque son coût
était quand même assez minimum donc ils
ont pu boucler leur budget et donc c'est
encore un exemple la de réalisation
d'innovations frugal qui influent sur la
vie quotidienne
mais les relations se gâte c'est aussi
un challenge industriels il va falloir
vraisemblablement modifier les méthodes
de marketing produit de recherche et
développement de l'industrialisation de
fabrication voire même de 10 de
distribution certaines sociétés
pionnières se sont déjà engagés dans
leur politique industrielle dans
l'innovation frugal on peut citer
general electric on peut citer renault
alors renault on connaît bien en france
quand il ya dix ans le programme de la
dacia a été lancée et il ça a été lancée
sur le principe de l'innovation frugal
donc simple diminuer la complexité du
produit simple même enlever tout le
superflu revenir à l'essence du produit
lui-même ce projet que peu de personnes
approuvaient et on en quelle peu de
personnes croyaient au démarrage a été
un succès est toujours un succès au bout
de dix ans
un autre exemple industriel un peu plus
confidentielle pour nous en france c'est
lui qui coule alors mythique houle c'est
un réfrigérateur sans électricité qui
est basée sur la principe de
l'évaporation de l'eau à travers une
paroi d'argile c'est une invention
indienne ça a été inventé par un potier
dans un village après un tremblement de
terre donc très faible coût 50 dollars
donc accessible par la population rurale
et le succès de cette entreprise a fait
à fait que le bazile forbes a nommé cet
entrepreneur un des mets des
entrepreneurs indiens les plus influents
donc encore une fois une très bonne
adaptation à la problématique économique
et local des matériaux locaux
c'est toujours de l'innovation frugal
maintenant on a fait un constat on l'a
fait on a regardé ce que faisaient les
pionniers maintenant il faut agir faut
avancer
agir avant c'est ça veut dire codifié
cette démarche de l'innovation frugal
pour l'instant elle a été elle a été
observée elle a été relevé
il faut aussi former accompagner les
gens qui vont prendre cette voie il faut
donc former des chercheurs des
ingénieurs
il faut sensibiliser les entrepreneurs
et les groupes r&d existants et puis
aussi il faut développer les lieux de
connexion entre le citoyen l'entreprise
et la recherche puisque cette démarche
innovation frugal ne peut venir que du
citoyen et de consommateurs alors il ya
plein de solutions pour agir une qui me
tient à coeur c'est la nouvelle chaire
industrielle de l'université de paris
saclay qui a été créé il ya moins de
huit jours et dont le je pense que le
communiqué de presse doivent être
publiés aujourd'hui son acronyme 3 inf
comprend industriels il gît neri
innovation et frugalité
donc ça va être un outil au niveau de
l'université paris saclay nouveau pour
développer ces notions d'une innovation
frugal et ça montre bien aussi que ce
concept va devenir un enjeu assez
importants pour l'avenir
je voudrais pour conclure remercié à la
sto
il a malheureusement disparu je pense
que 1 et ce taux n'a jamais imaginé
qu'un jour son arc musical se ferait en
tant que jusqu'au plateau de paris
saclay je vous remercie